elle sera candidate à la verrière cette
fois ci pour un mandat complet bonsoir
nelly du tube maire sortant de
communistes vous conduirez la liste la
verrière en commun on rappelle que vous
avez pris la suite d'un arrachage en
cours de mandat de maire qui était maire
depuis 2012 et qui a démissionné en 2016
pour raisons de santé
pourquoi être candidat de cette fois ci
pour un mandat complet bien parce que je
pense qu'on a depuis les quatre ans que
je suis là j'ai j'ai suivi le programme
de 2014
je les mener à bien au bout
on a pris nos marques on a fait l'équipe
et moi
on a rénové un certain nombre
d'équipements sur la ville on a eu
beaucoup de projets il ya l'anru qui est
repartie ya
la zac gare bécane qui repart et des
projets plus sociaux j'ai envie de dire
et donc je j'ai beaucoup de projets dans
la tête des choses aussi bien sûr au
service de derrière moi donc je repars
donc de jeter les choses encore à faire
et vous le disiez ce qui avait été
promis dans cette mandature depuis 2014
a été réalisée dans la grande majorité
bien sûr bien sûr donc la crèche en
faisait partie
elle va avoir les premiers coups de
pioche autour du mois de mars avril
donc voilà
il ya des choses en plus puisque la
rénovation des espaces du parc n'était
pas prévu mais on a on a saisi
l'occasion que nous tendait le
département
l'anru était mal parti on l'a remis sur
les rails
donc oui oui on a on a fait beaucoup je
pense qu'on n'a pas à rougir de notre du
mandat qu'on a qu'on a effectués jeu
c'est vrai que je suis arrivé en milieu
de mandat je pense pont il a fallu un
petit temps de la population mais je
suis bien dans cette fonction maintenant
et je vous dis je
on a pleins pleins d'idées à défendre
dans le dans la perspective d'améliorer
la vie de tous les jours des verriers
roi alors la verrière c'est une ville
communiste depuis les années 1970
et si une ville où la gauche partira dit
viser pour ces élections aux élus de la
majorité dont quatre adjoints sont
menées par jean-yves blé ils vont
également conduire une liste ils avaient
pris leurs distances avec vous il ya un
an dénonçant à l'époque un manque de
concertation
est ce que ça vous a fait douter dans
votre envie de vous présenter ce cette
scission pas du tout pas du tout
le procès qui m'est fait deux
d'un manque de concertation j'avoue ne
pas trop le comprendre les concertations
des a toujours mené même plus de
réunions que tout seul qui doivent avoir
lieu
lance enfin puisqu'il ya eu il ya eu des
débats autour de la crèche eux
je regardais monsieur blé la dernière
fois lui même dit qu'il est c'est lui
qui a eu l'idée de la mettre à la pmi
oui bah il y avait plusieurs y avait
plusieurs endroits à la m j'ai écouté on
a voté on était à l'unanimité moins deux
voix sur sur l'emplacement
tout allait bien et dans ce coup quelque
chose des rails
bon je vais laisser la responsabilité à
chacun chacun sa façon de voir les
choses que ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
un risque d'alternance que finalement la
gauche perde la verrière non non vous il
ya au fait pour ceux qui ferment parce
que ce n'est quand même pas moi ça ne
parle pas de ce n'est pas moins kif
semer la division du coup est ce qu'il
ya une subtilité de réconciliation ou
c'est pas à l'ordre du jour
je n'ai jamais demandé aux gens de
partir je l'aurais même proposé de
rester et jusqu'à aujourd'hui alors que
[Musique]
le monsieur blé etc quand les anciens
élus enfin les élus d'aujourd'hui font
une liste ils sont toujours adjoint je
les ai pas
je n'aurais pas enlever leur mandat et
du coup quid de votre liste escale est
complète aujourd'hui elle est complète
vous avez trouvé l'ensemble de vos
colistiers ce que vous la liste est
complète g
alors vous allez me demander mais j'ai
le soutien de mon parti du de bajus
quand je vais vous le demander dans les
sables tu sentais bien et c'est normal
non j'ai le soutien de ma section de mon
département et du national il ya je n'ai
aucun souci de ce côté là et à côté de
ça mon sujet n'est pas tant ça que
d'avoir une liste qui représente
les habitants de la verrière la grande
grande grande majorité de son quartier
nulle part mais on partage on partage
des valeurs on partage la notion du
service public la notion du bien commun
et c'est ça qui privait des gilles qui
est privilégiée dans cette liste mais
c'est d'associer peut-être les habitants
à votre démarche vous avez souhaité
construire votre programme avec les
verriers roi il ya des ateliers qui ont
été organisées depuis octobre pourquoi
cette démarche n'est pas parce que je me
semble que pour faire un programme qui
correspond aux habitants il vaut
peut-être mieux les écouter d'abord voir
ou ou malgré et malgré tout ce qu'on a
fait et où ça à pêcher quand même parce
que bon on n'est pas non plus à 100 % de
ce qu'on a fait qu'est ce qui pour eux
est important qu est-ce qui voudrait
changer en priorité donc il faut d'abord
peut-être un peu écouté les gens avant
de leur proposer d un programme qui
correspond quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui n'est pas encore prêt ou
dans les grandes lignes en tout cas on a
en a effectivement récolter les
doléances j'ai envie de dire de des
verriers roi aurait avec ça on est en
train de travailler sur un programme qui
correspondent à la teneur de ce qu'on a
eue avec qu est ce qui ressort des
priorités justement derrière oissel
qu'ils identifient aux courses et
l'éducation l'éducation des enfants
la formation des jeunes des 16-25
l'emploi bien sûr ouais la période à 16
% de chômage ça c'est une thématique il
est qui les inquiète si ben et son
ballon quand même
je comprends qu'avec 7% de chômage ya un
souci quand même on a un quartier qui
est en dessous du seuil de pauvreté et
40 % des gens sont en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
c'est normal que les parents
s'inquiètent de l'avenir de leurs
enfants et demande une aide de ce côté
là alors l'aide est l'escalet puisque on
est une commune on n'est ni une
entreprise ni l'éducation nationale mais
je peux encore en parler mais on peut
aider
il ya plein de choses à faire on est en
train d'en de deux mètres d'expérimenter
peut-être des choses dans le programme
qu'on va qu'on va sortir un mot vous
parler de la rénovation urbaine
justement cette rénovation urbaine du
bois de l'étang
vous souhaitez vous plutôt une
réhabilitation puis puis sans
destruction par une réhabilitation
plutôt qu'une destruction c'est ça alors
l'anru on l'a on a savez bien que enfin
il ya eu un moment très très compliqué
il ya quelques années
quand j'ai repris les discussions mon
grand souci était d'apaiser les choses
déjà et après de recommencer à discuter
avec la population du bois de l'étang
on a eu des comités de vie et de
voisinage ça fait déjà quasiment deux
ans qu'on en a à peu près tous les mois
et demi deux 2 mois on a recommencé à
discuter dans la confiance revient petit
à petit et il y avait cette question
centrale de la démolition
au bout d'un moment il m'a semblé
important de prendre position parce
qu'autrement on restait dans du fou et
on n'arrivait pas en sortir
donc j'ai pris position contre les
démolitions plusieurs points mais et g
le conseil municipal a voté
majoritairement contre les démolitions
une question car vous êtes aussi vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge de l'économie sociale et
solidaire voilà j'avais perdu ma fiche
est ce que le travail mené avec
l'agglomération est satisfaisant
aujourd'hui vous souhaitez renforcer
davantage les liens je pense que de ce
côté là on peut faire beaucoup beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus et notamment mené des
projets il ya le doublement de la
villedieu qui est un projet qui pourrait
arriver
alors ça c'est
le ce serait bien ce serait bien le
matin tout est engorgé de part et
d'autre du pont
dans la transversale plus pareil là il
ya vraiment de quoi réfléchir à une
meilleure
être desservis parce qu'il ya toute la
zone industrielle de trappes elancourt
qui est là là il ya vraiment une
réflexion à avoir
oui dernière chose pardon est ce que
vous avez un prochain rendez vous une
réussite
une réunion avec les habitants ah oui on
a d'abord les voeux puisque mes voeux
sont ouverts à toute la population est
en général elle répond bien présente
et puis le 31 décembre c'est la liste de
la verrière en commun qui
qui appelle les gens à venir partager
une galette est aussi 31 janvier vous
avez dit 31 décembre sera d'affranchir
janvier 31 rendez vous le 31 janvier 31
janvier merci où on va entre autres
présenté nos candidats merci nelly
youtube maire sortant communiste de la
dernière tête de liste de la verrière en
commun pour ces prochaines élections
municipales et en face de vous je
précise il y aura jean yves blé nicolas
dainville et également girard claude
morfin qui conduira une liste la
verrière citoyenne